.
>> I LOVE YOU, D. LEMON.
MAKE YOUR WITNESS.
>>> THIS IS DON LEMON TONIGHT.
WE'VE GOT BREAKING NEWS ON A BIG
NIGHT.
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN SPEAKING
DIRECTLY TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AT OUR CNN TOWN HALL IN
BALTIMORE.
ANDERSON, GREAT JOB OF
MODERATING THAT.
AND MAKING NEWS.
THE PRESIDENT WENT BEYOND
ANYTHING THAT HE HAS SAID BEFORE
ABOUT THE FILIBUSTER.
WATCH THIS AND WATCH HIS BODY
LANGUAGE.
>> ARE YOU SAYING ONCE YOU GET
THIS CURRENT AGENDA PASSED ON
SPENDING AND SOCIAL PROGRAMS
THAT YOU WOULD BE OPEN TO
FUNDAMENTALLY ALTERING THE
FILIBUSTER OR DOING AWAY WITH
IT?
>> WELL, THAT REMAINS TO BE
SEEN, EXACTLY WHAT THAT MEANS IN
TERMS OF FUNDAMENTALLY ALTERING
IT, WHETHER OR NOT WE JUST END
THE FILIBUSTER STRAIGHT UP.
THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS THAT
ARE JUST SACRED RIGHTS.
ONE IS A SACRED OBLIGATION WE'RE
NEVER GOING TO RENEGE ON A DEBT.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO VOTING
RIGHTS JUST SO I'M CLEAR,
THOUGH, YOU WOULD ENTERTAIN THE
NOTION OF DOING AWAY WITH THE
FILIBUSTER ON THAT ONE ISSUE?
IS THAT CORRECT?
>> AND MAYBE MORE.
>> AND MAYBE OTHER ISSUES.
>> YOU SEE THAT?
AND MAYBE MORE.
MAKING THE POINT OF WHAT I WAS
TRYING TO MAKE TO CHRIS THERE.
ANOTHER BIG MOMENT, THOUGH, THE
PRESIDENT ADMITTING THAT IT
WASN'T APPROPRIATE FOR HIM TO
SAY ANYBODY WHO REFUSES A
SUBPOENA FROM THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE SHOULD BE PROSECUTED
BY THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
AND LISTEN TO HIS ANSWER TO A
VOTER WHO ASKED WHY HE DOESN'T
DO WHAT REPUBLICANS DO AND JUST
PUSH HIS AGENDA THROUGH?
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN, I HAD SO
MUCH FAITH IN YOUR ELECTION WIN,
BUT BASED ON HISTORY THE
BIPARTISAN EFFORTS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ARE HELD
HOSTAGE BY ROGUE MODERATES AND
REPUBLICANS.
WHY NOT DO LIKE THE REPUBLICANS
AND USHER THROUGH THE DEMOCRATIC
AGENDA?
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> WELL, THREE REASONS.
IF YOU NOTICE THE REPUBLICANS
HAVEN'T PASSED A SINGLE SOLITARY
THING, ZERO.
SO USHER THROUGH THEIR AGENDA,
THEIR AGENDA RIGHT NOW IS JUST
STOP BIDEN OTHERWISE WE
SHOULDN'T MAKE IT SO PERSONAL,
STOP MY ADMINISTRATION.
THAT'S WHAT THE AGENDA IS.
AS MUCH AS IT IS TO STOP
SOMETHING THAN TO START
SOMETHING THEN WE'RE DOWN TO
FOUR OR FIVE ISSUES I'M NOT
GOING TO NEGOTIATE ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION.
BUT ALL KIDDING ASIDE BUT I
THINK WE CAN GET THERE.
>> SO INTERESTING.
CAN YOU IMAGINE?
WE HAVEN'T HAD THAT IN A WHILE,
A PRESIDENT ACTUALLY ADMITTING I
SHOULDN'T HAVE SAID SOMETHING, I
WAS WRONG TO SAY THAT.
THAT'S BIG.
AND THEN SAYING YOU KNOW WHAT?
THEIR AGENDA IS TO STOP ME OR MY
ADMINISTRATION, I SHOULDN'T MAKE
THIS PERSONAL.
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
PRESIDENT BIDEN PROMISING TO
MAKE GOVERNMENT WORK FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
BUT NINE MONTHS SINCE HE TOOK
THE OATH OF OFFICE, CAN HE GET
HIS PARTY TO GET OUT OF ITS OWN
WAY AND MAKE IT HAPPEN?
THAT IS THE QUESTION.
A LOT TO TALK ABOUT.
CNN'S KAITLAN COLLINS IS HERE,
AS WELL AS DAVID CHALIAN AND NIA
MALIKA HENDERSON.
KAITLAN, I'M GOING TO START WITH
YOU.
THE PRESIDENT TALKING ABOUT THE
FILIBUSTER TO FUNDAMENTALLY
ALTER IT IN SOME WAY.
>> DON, I AGREE WITH YOU I
ACTUALLY THINK THAT WAS ONE OF
NEWS WORTHIEST ANSWERS THE
PRESIDENT GAVE DURING THIS TOWN
HALL.
AND I THINK THE REASON IT'S
IMPORTANT IS IT'S OBVIOUS THE
PRESIDENT DOESN'T HAVE A VOTE
WHEN IT COMES TO THE FILIBUSTER.
H
IT'S SYMBOLIC TO HIM.
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO SPENT THREE
DECADES IN THE
SENATE.
SO TO AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
SEEMS TO BE WEIGHING ON THE
PRESIDENT WHEN HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT THAT TONIGHT.
THOUGH HE SAID THERE COULD BE
OTHER REASONS TO GET RID OF THE
FILIBUSTER OR --
>> MORE THINGS BEYOND THAT HE'S
WILLING TO FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE
OR MORE ISSUES, OTHER ISSUES
RATHER THAN JUST VOTING RIGHTS
BECAUSE I WASN'T QUITE CLEAR OF
WHAT HE MEANT BY MORE.
>> I THINK ANDERSON'S FOLLOW IS
WAS THIS SOMETHING THAN JUST FOR
VOTING RIGHTS AND THE PRESIDENT
SAID, QUOTE, MAYBE MORE OF
COURSE HINTING THERE COULD BE
MORE TO COME ON THAT, WHICH IS
INCREDIBLY SIGNIFICANT.
OF COURSE HE DID TALK ABOUT THE
REALITIES OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW WHEN IT COMES TO THE
FILIBUSTER.
BECAUSE HE SAYS IF HE GOT INTO A
DEBATE ABOUT THE FILIBUSTER AT
THIS TIME HE'D LOSE THREE VOTES
ON THIS BIG ECONOMIC PACKAGE THE
DEMOCRATS ARE STILL NEGOTIATING
OVER, AND HE NEEDS THE SUPPORT
OF EVERY SINGLE SENATE DEMOCRAT.
BUT HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
POWER SENATE DEMOCRATS HAVE OVER
HIS AGENDA, WE'LL GET INTO THAT
AND THE DILLS HE'LL REVEAL HERE
TONIGHT, BUT SAYING THAT ABOUT
THE FILIBUSTER IS SYMBOLIC.
WE'VE HEARD FROM SENATOR JOE
MANCHIN AND OTHERS SAY THEY'RE
OPPOSED TO THE FILIBUSTER, EVEN
HAVING A CARVE OUT TO SOMETHING
WE WERE DISCUSSING.
BUT I DO THINK IT'S SIGNIFICANT
FOR THE PRESIDENT TO SAY THERE
COULD BE A DAY WHEN THEY DO
DECIDE TO FUNDAMENTALLY ALTER
IT, AND IT DOES MAKE YOU THINK
ABOUT THE TRAJECTORY IF THEY GET
THIS ECONOMIC PACKAGE PASSED,
HOW HE THEN FOCUSES ON THAT.
>> YEAH, IT WAS INTERESTING.
TO YOUR POINT HE SAID WHEN YOU
HAVE A SLIM MAJORITY LIKE THAT,
WHEN IT'S 50, YOU HAVE 50
PRESIDENTS, MORE THAN JUST HIM.
DAVID, AS HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
THE FILIBUSTER, YOU KNOW, I WAS
THINKING IT'S WHAT HE'S NOT
SAYING.
HE EXPLAINED WHAT HE HAD TO GET
DONE FIRST, WHAT HE THOUGHT HIS
FIRST PRIORITY WAS AND THAT'S
HIS ECONOMIC AGENDA, AND HE
WOULD WORRY ABOUT VOTING RIGHTS.
AND I WILL TALK TO NIA IS,
SECOND, IF THAT'S THE RIGHT
THING.
ISN'T WHAT HE DOESN'T SAY THERE
OR WHAT HE COULD NOT SAY?
>> I'M WITH YOU.
I DON'T KNOW I UNDERSTAND FULLY
CHRIS' READ ON THIS.
I THOUGHT IT WAS VERY
SIGNIFICANT.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT PUT
HIMSELF IN A DIFFERENT POSITION
ON THIS LONG RUNNING DEBATE
ABOUT THE FILIBUSTER WHICH IS
PREVENTING SOME MAJOR AGENDA
ITEMS WHETHER VOTING RIGHTS,
POLICE REFORM, WHAT HAVE YOU?
BY THE WAY, WHEN HE SAID MAYBE
MORE I MEAN HE INDICATED ONE OF
THE OTHER THINGS BEYOND VOTING
RIGHTS THAT HE WANTS TO GET RID
OF THE FILIBUSTER ON POTENTIALLY
WHICH IS DEALING WITH THE DEBT
CEILING BECAUSE WE JUST WENT
THROUGH A WHOLE PROCESS WHERE
REPUBLICANS WERE FILIBUSTERING,
THREATENING TO FILIBUSTER, THE
WHOLE NOTION OF RAISING THE
NATION'S DEBT LIMITS SO THAT
AMERICA DOES NOT GO INTO ITS
FIRST DEFAULT EVER IN ITS
HISTORY AND SEND THE ECONOMY
INTO A TOTAL TAILSPIN,
POTENTIALLY.
SO HE CLEARLY IS GIVING THIS
SOME THOUGHT, AND I THOUGHT
TONIGHT JUST EMERGED IN A
TOTALLY DIFFERENT PLACE.
AND I THINK THIS IS SO
INTERESTING.
WE RARELY GET -- RARELY GET REAL
CANDID OUT LOUD THOUGHTS ABOUT
THE POLITICS OF A MOMENT.
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE USUALLY GET
FROM A POLITICIAN.
>> DID HE SAY SOMETHING THAT'S A
FACT JACK OR SOMETHING YOU COULD
LAUGH OR WHATEVER BUT THAT'S THE
TRUTH --
>> HE'S JUST SAYING LIKE I DON'T
WANT TO TRIP UP MY ECONOMIC
AGENDA BY INJECTING AN EFFORT
RIGHT NOW TO GET RID OF THE
FILIBUSTER.
THAT IS GOING TO BE THE NEXT
PROJECT.
I NEED ALL THOSE SENATORS RIGHT
NOW.
HE JUST PUT IT OUT PLAINLY TO
PEOPLE IN HIS BASE I THINK MOST
IMPORTANTRY TO HEAR WHY HE
HASN'T MADE GETTING RID OF THE
FILIBUSTER ON VOTING RIGHTS A
HIGHER PRIORITY.
IT'S BECAUSE HE NEEDS THOSE
VOTES ON THE ECONOMIC PACKAGE.
>> USUALLY PEOPLE SAY HOW DOES
IT PLAY IN PIORIA.
THE QUESTION IS HOW DOES THIS
PLAY IN PHILADELPHIA, CHICAGO,
IN BALTIMORE?
HOW DOES IT PLAY IN CITIES WHERE
LARGE GROUPS OF
AFRICAN-AMERICANS SHOWED UP AND
MADE HIM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES?
>> YOU KNOW, LISTEN, THOSE FOLKS
WANT TO HEAR MORE.
PROGRESSIVES WANT TO HEAR MORE
FROM HIM ON THE FILIBUSTER.
I THINK THEY WILL BE PLEASED
WHAT THEY HEARD FROM HIM TONIGHT
GOING A LITTLE BIT FURTHER
SAYING HE MIGHT BE WILLING FOR A
CARVE OUT ON VOTING RIGHTS AND
OTHER ISSUES.
PROBABLY THE BIGGER QUESTION,
THOUGH, IS HOW DOES IT PLAY IN
WEST VIRGINIA?
AND HOW DOES IT PLAY IN ARIZONA
WITH --
>> SMART LADY YOU ARE.
>> -- WITH SINEMA AND MANCHIN.
THEY SEEM WITH THE FILIBUSTER
NOT WILLING TO THINK ABOUT ANY
SORT OF CARVEOUTS FOR ANY OF
THESE ISSUES.
JOE MANCHIN'S BILL WAS SORT OF
THE SKINNY VOTING RIGHTS BILL
THAT WAS PUT ON THE FLOOR OF THE
SENATE, AND IT GOT NO REPUBLICAN
VOTES.
SO I THINK IF YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT
AND YOU'RE HOPING THAT PERHAPS
THE REPUBLICAN OBSTINENCE ON
VOTING RIGHTS WILL MOVE JOE
MANCHIN, MOVE SENATOR SINEMA,
WE'LL SEE IF THAT HAPPENS.
AND THEN YOU ADD THAT UP WITH
WHAT BIDEN SAID TODAY, MAYBE YOU
GET SOMEWHERE.
BUT SO FAR EVEN GIVEN WHAT BIDEN
SAID TONIGHT, I THINK IF YOU'RE
A PROGRESSIVE YOU'RE STILL
LOOKING AT A PRESIDENT SINEMA
AND PRESIDENT MANCHIN ON THIS
ISSUE BECAUSE THEY HOLD THE KEYS
TO THE KINGDOM WHEN IT COMES TO
THIS VERY CRITICAL ISSUE OF
DEMOCRACY AND VOTING RIGHTS,
SOMETHING THAT OR FOREFATHERS
FOUGHT AND MARCHED FOR AND DIED
FOR THAT IS VERY MUCH UNDER
ASSAULT IN THIS COUNTRY BEING
ROLED BACK IN SEVERAL STATES.
>> DON'T YOU THINK HE WAS VERY
CANDID ABOUT HIS NEGOTIATIONS
WITH THEM -- WHERE HE STANDS
WITH THEM AND HIS AGENDA AND
WHAT HE'S TRYING TO DO?
AND I THINK WITHOUT GOING TOO
FAR BECAUSE I'M NOT SURE.
I WISH YOU COULD SEE AFTERWARDS
I WAS STRUCK BY HIM HOLDING HIS
HEAD DOWN THINKING ABOUT WHAT HE
HAD JUST SAID.
AND I THINK HE WAS THINKING DID
I ANSWER THAT CORRECTLY BECAUSE,
YES, AFRICAN-AMERICANS
OVERWHELMINGLY SUPPORTED ME.
AND THAT'S IT.
THIS WAS AFTER HIS ANSWER, YOU
KNOW?
>> YEAH, I MEAN HE IS HEARING
FROM CONSTITUENTS ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
PROGRESSIVES ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
AND THEY ARE UNNERVED BY WHERE
THIS IS RIGHT NOW, WHICH IS
NOWHERE.
THREE TIMES NOW THIS HAS BEEN
BLOCKED BY REPUBLICANS IN THE
SENATE.
THEY ARE ASKING THEMSELVES WHAT
THE HELL IS THE PRESIDENCY FOR,
RIGHT, IF YOU ARE NOT GOING TO
DO SOMETHING ON THIS FUNDAMENTAL
ISSUE, OVERWHELMING SUPPORT